هنا في باريس التي زار هذا ليسكي بعد روما
وبرلين وقبل لندن كان ابرز ما قاله ماكرون
امام ضيفه ان فرنسا سترسل المزيد من
الصواريخ الى اوكرانيا لكن الاهم من ذلك
قول الرئيس الفرنسي ان مدى هذه الصواريخ
سيكون ابعد من مدى تلك التي ارسلتها باريس
سابقا الى ما سيمكن هذه الاخيره بحسب
الرئيس الفرنسي من الشروع في شن هجومها
المضاد على الجيش الروسي فرنسا ستقوم ايضا
بتاهيل طيارين عسكريين اوكرانيين وهنا
يرصد الاليزي التعليق حول امكانيه الربط
بين هذه الخطوه واحتمال ارسال باريس يوما
ما طائرات مقاتله الى كييف وسيرسل
الفرنسيون ايضا المزيد من المركبات
المدرعه والدبابات الخفيفه ومنظومات
الدفاع الجوي تقول باريس ان هدف تكثيف
دعمها لاوكرانيا عسكريا دفاعي لا هجومي
عندما دخلت روسيا الى اوكرانيا خرقت ميثاق
الامم المتحده الاوكرانيون يدافعون عن
انفسهم ولذلك تعطيهم فرنسا السلاح روسيا
بلد يعتدي في كل الاتجاهات لا يمكن اجراء
حوار معبوت الذي يسعى الى اجتياح الدول
المجاوره ووضعها تحت سيطرته الدعم الفرنسي
لاوكرانيا ياتي في سياق دعم اوروبي واسع
النطاق تقول باريس انه قد يعدل موازين
القوى العسكري لصالح
هنا استقبل المستشار الالماني قبل بضعه
ايام الرئيس الاوكراني
بحضوره عن اكبر حزمه مساعدات عسكريه
تقدمها برلين لكياف منذ بدايه الحرب بقيمه
ثلاثه مليارات دولار امريكي لتصبح المانيا
بذلك ثاني اكبر مانع عسكري لاوكرانيا بعد
الولايات المتحده حزمه المساعدات
الالمانيه الجديده تضم 30 دبابه ليوبارت
كانت ترددت المانيا بالموافقه على تسليمها
ما تسبب بتوتر العلاقه بين الطرفين الحزمه
الضخمه الجديده تطم ايضا 20 ناقله جنود
مدرعه من نوع ماردر اضافه الى اربعه انظمه
ايريس المتطوره المضاده للطائرات
المساعدات التي قدمت الى الجانب الاوكراني
هي مساعدات للدفاع والاستعاده على الاراضي
الروسيه التي الاوكرانيه التي تم
استحلالها احتلالا من قبل الجانب الروسي
بمعنى اخر
لم يتم اعطاء او لم يتم الموافقه على
اعطاء طائرات هجوميه او صواريخ هجوميه حتى
ان تلك الانظمه الصاروخيه التي اعطيت الى
الجانب الاوكراني لا يتعدى مداها ال 120
كيلومتر اسلحه المانيه جديده يامل الرئيس
الاوكراني ان تساعد على بدء الهجوم المؤجل
لدفع القوات الروسيه على الانسحاب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات